hello I'm Rick Franks and welcome to the
european premiere of one of the most
eagerly anticipated films of the year
join me as I enter the wizarding world
of fantastic beasts and where to find
them
first up let's me the star of the show
the incredibly talented Eddie Redmayne
will introduce us to news commander the
world-renowned matches neurologist years
ago the case full of Martha's then news
travels flush Newt is a self-proclaimed
Majesty wanna just about he arrives in
New York with it case full of creatures
that he's saved that is looking after
and he's he's not particular with humans
bright really wonderful with preachers
and he has a warm heart from the
visionary minds of JK Rowling fantastic
piece is an exciting adventure featuring
some incredible characters and of course
the only way to immerse yourself and
this I papi what Buster is to watch it
in I mice this is a story that i have
loved telling and I've had in my head
for a while and I really hope they love
it because I think we filmmakers and I
are very proud of it but there's
absolutely nothing to worry about well
there's a lot of familiar in that their
time that the light versus dark there's
the incredible friendships and
characters that she creates and you have
these creatures who are just like other
Lee wonderful I used to go and watch the
Potter films for a kind of JK Rowling
hug every year or two to dive back into
that world and and I hope it has all of
those elements but with a freshness
thrown out of Hogwarts for ending
life that was next reiterating the
magical world of 1920s New York was no
easy task but luckily the film was in
safe hands with Harry Potter veteran
director David Yates fantastic beasts
and where to find them land itself so
perfectly to the omics format because
you know the movies an immersive
experience and sometimes when you see
that on a big screen there's something
you want to fall into the story you know
and it's sort of overwhelms you and
there are some big set pieces in this
movie there's two imax there's a
thriller quality there's a sort of
darkness to it but there's high comedy
and heart this is an epic and what
better format to see an epic than I
meant it's been an incredible evening
but now it's time to need to enter the
Wizarding World myself don't forget to
watch fantastic beasts and where to buy
them in imax
you